on governor sisolak he is now responding
to president donald trump's comments
the i-team's vanessa murphy interviewed
the governor and vanessa now joins us
live with
more hi vanessa
hi brian governor steve sisselek says he
believes the rallies held by president
donald trump will cause
a spike in covid 19 cases i was given
a very short time to speak with the
governor here's some of what he had to
say
let's start with president donald trump
he called you a political hack
told his supporters to tell your
governor to open
up your state your response well
i think that i don't know where he comes
up with the political hack i thought he
was talking about his golf game or
something i don't know
uh you know i don't know how i can
respond to president trump and what he
said
his actions were selfish reckless
irresponsible
he jeopardized the health and safety
of every person that lives in the state
of nevada and there's just
no excuse for what he did i mean he knew
what the rules were
those rules were developed in
coordination with the white house
what about the criticism that the
protests
that have happened the protests that
have been happening
don't get as much criticism
okay well the protests get plenty of
criticism the difference is that you
have a business let's take for example
a gathering businesses we can regulate
uh because they're licensed
and you go in like a casino could not
have what they did at that manufacturing
facility
uh because they have a gaming license
and they know what the rules are
but you can't control the casinos are
having a real problem
if you're inside the casino you're going
to follow the guidelines
you walk out on the strip after you
leave one casino walking to another one
or you walk on fremont street there's
really nobody in charge of you when
you're out there
we don't have law enforcement handing
out tickets the president
is saying you were behind this effort to
make sure his rallies
and campaign events did not happen you
said you were
not part of that the next question is
no one from your office no one from your
administration made
any phone calls no one made
any phone calls with these rallies you
know i read about him in the paper
and online just like everybody else did
certainly no love lost between the
president
and the governor and you know nevada was
recently denied federal funding to
help keep the nevada national guard here
governor sisilak
is saying the president is inconsistent
with how he helps
states and the decisions made back to
you and vanessa how about governor
sislek in terms of the city of henderson
does he think
they should have possibly done anything
else or anything more to prevent the
rally
from even happening in the first place
yeah brian i asked him about that he did
not want to criticize the city of
henderson he pointed out that henderson
did take action as we reported the
business will be fined
back to you all right thank you vanessa
for that report